according to the better sleep council
when it surveyed people nationwide a
quarter of them said they're
dissatisfied with the quality of their
sleep now fortunately there are key
things you can do to set yourself up for
success when it comes to sleeping
consumer advocate elizabeth leamy shares
five ways to make over your bedroom for
a better night's rest
if you're dreaming of a better night's
sleep follow these steps
number one the better sleep counsel
suggests evaluating your mattress for
support every seven years another
consideration look for a mattress made
with foam certified by serta pure us a
non-profit that conducts testing to make
sure mattress foam is made without
chemicals of concern
update your pillow if you fold it in
half and it fails to bounce back it's
past its prime
figure out whether you sleep better
between crisp per kale sheets or silky
satin sheets
invest in blackout blinds and remove
electronics that emit light
alternatively you can cover up any
lights with electrical tape
lower your thermostat to 60 to 67
degrees overnight for more ideas go to
bedroom dash makeover dot com